from sky
now you've criticized Richard C Knight
yesterday for being light on policy but
when it comes to the big issues that are
impacting people right now NHS pay the
strikes
what exactly are you going to do to help
people it's not clear what you're saying
Beyond saying that you would do better
job than the Tories you say you're not
willing to get your big checkbook out
but how are you going to fix those
problems help people right now what
difficult decisions are you going to be
willing to make uh well look Ali I mean
look I have criticized the Prime
Minister you're absolutely right I
thought his promises were weak and low
ambition
um inflation is the biggest example of
that saying inflation down to the rate
lower than has already predicted is not
a big promise to the British public and
the idea that after 13 years of failure
can come along in the 13th year and say
I've got five new promises please give
us one more chance I just feel is so far
removed from reality but in relation to
your question obviously the things we
need to do this winter to get us through
and we've argued the case for
discharging patients more quickly
virtual Wards there are many things
we're making use of facility it is but
what we can't do and this is really the
centerpiece of what I'm trying to say is
every year we go into an NHS crisis it
just gets worse and worse and worse and
so we're in the worst one ever now and
that's sticking plaster politics we can
do something this year to get through
but if we don't actually understand the
fundamentals of change we'll be back in
the same crisis next year and the year
after and Central to that is the
workforce and that's why we've said that
we will have a fully funded plan to
bring in you know thousands and
thousands more nurses more doctors
Etc more medical staff coming into the
NHS because in the end that's the only
way we're going to get out of this that
long you know putting another sticking
plaster on is necessary of course it is
it's a bit like the energy and cost of
living crisis we've got to do it for the
one more winter but if we don't tackle
the fundamentals we'll be back in this
cycle next year and the year after the
year after and that's what's been one of
the biggest failures of politics in the
last 13 years